hey guys i'm thrilled to be sharing this
little mini interview with you
you probably saw the viral video of
corey and his beautiful young daughter
royalty this week
talking about how silly critical race
theory is and how we should judge people
by the content of their character
and not the color of their skin so i'm
going to sit down with them in just a
minute but in case you missed
the viral video here you go daddy
teaches you can be anything
in this world that you want to be right
don't daddy teach you that
yeah and it doesn't matter if you're
black or white or any color
it doesn't matter if you're black white
brown
yellow right black and how we treat
people is based on who they are
and not what color they are and if
they're nice and smart
see this is how this is how children
think right here
critical race theory wants to end that
not with my children it's not gonna
happen
my baby's gonna know that no matter what
she wants to be in life all she has to
do is work
hard and she can become that work hard
even though you don't know anyone you
can make friends
yeah you can make friends no matter what
color they are
so we need to stop crt period point
blank children do not see skin color man
they love everybody if they're good
people they love them
all right i am with corey and royalty
right now and royalty
i gotta talk to you first can you
believe
that you're an internet star can you
believe it and i guess how's that
lollipop more importantly
he's asking how's the lollipop
lollipops good yes all right we'll we'll
let her get
sugared up a little bit cory i mean you
put that thing out there on tick tock
did you have any idea what was about to
happen
uh you know i had no clue i had no clue
man
um it was crazy like i posted it and
then
like two weeks went by and then other
people start posting it
and all of a sudden you know it just
blew up
and and i'm just so grateful and
thankful that
people shared it you know i'm
appreciative
and yeah royalty how old are you
six six years old is that is that
kindergarten is that first grade
first grade first grade and your your
dad seems like he's a pretty good
teacher huh
yes corey when did you when did you wake
up to all of this stuff because i think
most people watching the video were like
yeah that's the truth
kids are kids people are people um but
it takes a lot for people to see through
the nonsense
yeah um i've been waking up to it for a
while now i'll say um
parents have been sending me different
videos and things and
um different curriculums and i've been
seeing different videos on the internet
and then my daughter had an incident at
her school with um
them teaching her about a segregation
you know what you want to tell them okay
then teaching her about segregation
and um like white only uh water
fountains and things like that
and i had to actually address the
principle about it
so yeah it's been going on for a while
what kind of pushback did you get when
you talk to the principal
um he it wasn't really any pushback he
just told me
that the teacher didn't really run it by
him she just
uh played the video right royalty how do
you like being in school
are you back in school are you are you
in school right now
yes well i mean now she just had her
last day
oh you just had your last day what what
summer
break oh very nice what are you gonna do
for the summer
go swimming and ride my bike
pretty good that's a good summer right
there um
corey what about just like within your
family and friends like just as a father
talking about this stuff do you do you
get pushback or are people with you
are people kind of quietly supporting
you um
actually that's funny you say that
because i just got a
call yesterday from a family member i
hadn't spoke to in at least a couple
years
and she was pretty upset she was pretty
angry that i was
um pushing back against critical race
theory
um and just just that i push a push back
against you know systematic racism and
all those different types of things too
and blm and all of that
so um yeah you know it's it's mixed in
the family but as far as
um people that uh text me or or dm
me i would say it's all love yeah
uh what do you do normally so you're
you're a content creator
is that is that on the side is that a
full-time job time
that's oh that's full time that's
awesome so tell the people more about
what you're doing
um yeah i'm just trying to spread the
message man i got my clothing line right
here
i do it with my cousin um godly vibes
is the website and yeah man we're just
trying to wake people up
that's that's uh what the mission is
about i actually have done
other videos this was just a video i did
with my daughter on critical race there
um but yeah i've been pushing back
against
um you know the mainstream media and
things like that for a while now
yeah royalty you like doing videos with
your dad
yeah yeah what's your favorite part
about doing videos with him
being with him
that's that's a good daughter and a good
father right there
what about in that message you were
saying things that you just want to be
nice to people and you want to be
friends with people right you don't care
about that other nonsense
he's asking you in the video are over
and you're saying doesn't matter what
color you are
you want to be nice to people he'll be
nice to you right
just ah she's she likes doing the the
handheld you know
right right right um
what else what else would you want
people to know i mean now a lot of
eyeballs are on you suddenly you're
you know your name was trending and
people were people were trying to find
out about you that video i mean it
really went bananas it's got to be seen
at least five million times already like
what else would you want people to know
right now right
um as far as the video goes um i want to
say thank you to everybody i
i really appreciate you guys sharing the
video
um i want people to know that we
should not look at each other and base
our relationships with each other off of
things as superficial as skin color or
race
you know i think that you love everybody
no matter what they look like you know
um it's who they are on the inside it's
their character that matters and that's
what i was trying to get across that's
what we were trying to get across
yeah do you like that message do you
like that message royalty
yeah yeah we should treat everybody how
they how they behave how they act
towards us pretty good right
yeah it's just it's just a beautiful
thing well listen corey if it's okay
i would like to send royalty you think
she could do something with maybe like a
hundred dollar amazon card is there
anything she might want to get
royalty is there anything you want is
there what if if you had a lamborghini
i'm a youtuber i'm a youtuber she has
never said that before to me ever
okay you hear this for the first time
i'm hearing this for the first time
a lamborghini you said it's a monumental
award
wow man i hope mommy's got a good job
um is there anything that might be a
little less expensive than a lamborghini
that would be pretty good what do you
like he's asking he wants to get it for
you
i want to get you something
you don't know american journal
american girl done all right that's it
you're gonna pick your american girl
doll you go to the website
and i'm gonna take care of it because i
think you're awesome and
you're you're spreading a lot of love in
the world and that's what we need right
now
thank you you're welcome at the
lamborghini you're gonna have to give me
a little time on that
here all right well listen you you guys
are both awesome and corey i'm gonna
i'm gonna text you separately we'll take
care of that and
royalty you are you are just a gem
and i i look forward to seeing what you
do in the world
thank you thank you thank you hey we
appreciate you man so much thank you
thank you guys awesome if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell